[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
the following is a presentation of the
st. Louis chess club
20 international chess professionals
compete in st. Louis as US chess jams
calm presents the second annual winter
chess classic in the midst of World
Championship fever we bring you the
winter chess classic where today the
fields could that is could be decided so
come on into the studio here Studio B
hello chess fans Ben Simon here along
with Grandmaster Jessie cry also known
by some other alias I suppose well Ben
we were all inspired you know when you
went away to do the announcing and we
were jealous I was jealous and so they
started calling me el macho and I you
know I kind of liked it so I've taken on
at least for today I'm el macho
spectacular I can't wait to encounter
this el macho so today World
Championship Game three was a draw
Karlsson Cara Juana you said that these
guys you're very impressed because
they've been playing fighting chess
every game is exciting despite the draws
give us your take right you know there's
some times you can look at some games
even here in this tournament there's a
couple where it looks like there's some
long theoretical thing and then it's
just a draw and then it feels like as a
fan myself on the con oh and then other
people are like I don't know and then
there's a certain moment where you can
feel like chess is dead or something and
I'm not seeing that for most part in the
tournament not seeing that I'm
definitely not seeing that in these
games here and what you're looking at
right now on the screen is a position
from Game three earlier today earlier
today that's right and for chess fans
out there you probably know Sicilian
hasn't been seen much recently and this
Bishop b5 thing we might see a lot of
this and it's a very interesting opening
then honestly it's a few similarities to
the Berlin where the whites going to
have
me down a light-square bishop in
compensation for some pawn weaknesses
but here the Queens do not instantly
come off in contrast to the Verlin so
it's a very rich maneuvering position
and let's look at what happened there's
a couple interesting MO I don't want to
go through the whole game we're in depth
but I just want to say a couple key
moments the first is this Queen c7 which
was it's a weird move kind of actually
very similar in my mind to fabi's rook
da in game 2 which was not it wasn't not
not not only not a very well known move
but it didn't look right in Queen c7
doesn't necessarily look right because
it's not clear it actually wants or
needs to go there so Fabi I thought got
a very pleasant position in contrast to
Magnus simple chest a3 before opening it
up and I didn't like this decision by
Magnus and so already I thought um white
had a very pleasant edge and it
definitely after a 5 the next critical
moment I want to say really the big
moment for Bobbie to seize the
initiative here was taking as he did by
the way a5 is the kind of move which
says I don't feel good about my position
and I'm ready to suffer
I just wanted to shut it all down B
takes rook takes in here you know I'm
interested to see what Bobby was saying
in the press conference but Bishop d2
looks like it just wins the a file you
got to give me the a file something like
this and instead of that Bobby play
Queen b1 and now just you got to do that
with the a file and nothing's going on
so a lot of people said here ok it's
just going to be a draw but then one of
the most amazing things about Magnus is
he'll I'll play you from nothing from
absolutely nothing here and in this
position Fabi really starts to drift and
I was watching this with our tournaments
own Eugene peril Stein and we were like
oh no oh no he's going to lose and if
you lose this position it's gonna be
yeah it's gonna be a heartbreak so Fabi
drifted and drifted and drifted here in
Knight g5 very this is the beginning of
the torture we're gonna force the pawn
to a dark square and it at first glance
it doesn't seem like it's at all
meaningful but after you start fixing it
you're like oh right these are on dark
squares this is a dark square Bishop and
these plants could become a victim and
so definitely the next several moves
Carlson was really on him f5 and this
was the move maybe that gave away the
chances to play Fe Laden you know [ __ ]
Magnus still had a lot of time left
coming up over 40 but this was the
critical moment with king c6 I think he
still puts great pressure on to Fabi so
in a lot of ways similar to Game one a
kind of lucky escape for Fabi and we're
gonna go into round four tomorrow where
we're gonna see you know well Magnus
repeat and I think he is I think he's
gonna repeat the same line we saw in
round two and this time not be afraid of
weird moves like rookie like they are
gonna go through all the weird loops and
they're gonna go through all of them and
make sure they're ready for all of
fabi's weird and really what is karma
what does the Karlsson want he wants a
position like we had at the end of this
game just some nice grind that he can
get and we have some of that going on in
our tournament today
all spectacular I want to remind you
tomorrow for Game four of the World
Championship st. Louis's coverage begins
at 11:00 a.m. Central Time two hours
after the beginning of the game just so
we have a little more bam-bam content
for you
u.s. chess champs calm the same way you
should be watching the winter chess
Classic so over to the winter chess
classic let's take a look at our
standings in Group A after seven rounds
just two left quesada in the lead by a
point and a half
so the situation here if he wins no
matter what anyone else does if he wins
today then he clinches this field he
leaves with the six grand it doesn't
look like that's going to happen and
play will continue for first
through tomorrow but we'll see we'll
keep an eye on his game now Group B is a
little bit of a similar situation zhabin
Andreotti and the armenian player is a
half point above the field now he's
playing mikhalev ski today big Nick he
wins and peril Stein in his game loses
well then on v.i.c n will clinch this
field today so it's possible in both
fields if you're just joining us the
tournament format its classical chess
it's a round-robin two of them the time
control is 90 minutes for the first 40
moves and in 30 minutes for the
remainder of the game there is a 30
second increment for a move number one
so you always have to take notation and
the players may not agree to a draw
before blacks thirtieth move to
encourage fighting chess tomorrow we
begin two hours earlier this is your
reminder now if we look at the schedule
1:00 p.m. every day so far the games
have been beginning tomorrow 11:00 a.m.
is when it starts Central Time
our show will come on the air two and a
half hours later as it always does we
will be with you at 1:30 p.m. Central
Time and you can watch it from beginning
to finish at us chess champs calm now
Jesse the reason why we're beginning
earlier tomorrow is because we're gonna
have playoffs if necessary and so that's
always exciting if we have to go to
playoffs but we may not have to let's
take a look at our pairings in Group A
these are the games already in progress
here at u.s. chess champs calm Santa
Karin versus milk cumbia Shimano versus
spirits Zhang versus mero multi-levels
Robson and Jesse I understand you're
gonna be channeling your inner wrestling
persona for this one in the blue corner
casada look at that eye that comes from
a bad accident and seve on the young
lamb will he be able to do any business
there I doubt it we will look we will
see let's see let's take a glance at the
game this position looks pretty equal
here I don't is there any play for
either
no I I you know it's interesting I so
it's been kind of equal ish the entire
time here but in this position with the
weakened pawns the lamb has some chances
here he also has a slightly better King
so let's back up just a little bit we
started let's turn let's say we started
this this kind of current situation here
and my sense just intuitively was that
Bishop g4 so it looks good for white
right better development knight on d5
that it seemed like after Bishop g4
black was gonna be able to mess up
White's coordination enough to at least
have equality for example after with d2
I was expecting something like Queen a5
maybe there's some problem with that and
see anyways casada plays Queen e8 one
thing I've seen with cassada in the
analysis is that he doesn't mind playing
out slightly inferior positions he's not
afraid like most I don't want a slightly
inferior position he really believes in
his defensive capabilities so let's look
at how this endgame happened
snip-snip check to the mister book King
and then snip and yeah I I think this is
dangerous for for Cassata you know
normally we say that the bishop is the
better piece in the endgame but that's
really when we have the potential for
passed pawns rolling on either side
whereas in this position what my sensei
Smith law says is that in positions
where there the knight can blockade or
with local weaknesses the knight is
superior and right away we can see what
he's talking about here at work this is
a nice blockading square for the knight
and this pawn is weak and the King the
White King is closer so I don't I mean
holy it just needed if I get a chance to
talk to casada again I feel like this is
dangerous for him which would totally
open up the tournament again if casado
loses today oh no doubt I mean that
would make for
interesting tomorrow right for certain
okay so these two actually met once
before it was actually 2016 kappa blanka
memorial these same colors Quesada was
able to defeat Samsa beyond even younger
than he is now of course right but Sam
two years ago I mean I think he was
about the same rating maybe he's a
little bit higher now but I don't think
it was a significant difference he's
been a grandmaster since 2014 right so
we'll see what happens in this game
enough with the trivia okay Group B
pairings let's take a look at what's
happening right now at us chess champs
calm how Kobe and versus Benjamin van
forest versus peril Stein chem plush
melee vs. grey of a lemur on D versus
Theodore oh okay is he coming back here
Jessie is he coming back for this key
matchup in the red corner big Mick he's
got such a nice face maybe you think
he's your accountant but no it's not
like that the man will hurt you I've
been hurt by him many others have they
know the pain oh my and he's trying to
put it on to the tournament leader right
now Andre Ossian who's been playing real
conservative chess but when you're
facing the big Mick it's like a bear and
you better be careful okay that's that
was the most information in one of these
previews we've had yeah thus far
let's uh let's take a glance as they
should look very important group B match
up and here we go yeah in this position
I don't think big Mick has anything to
worry about in fact there's been several
opportunities for big Mick to just
liquidate immediately into a pawn up
rook endgame that would be totally drawn
with by just playing rook c4 and
snipping the thing there's no way to not
you know to defend it
so I'm Andre ASEAN made a choice
basically several moves ago to just say
I'm gonna I'm gonna play for equality
here so big Mick you know it is true
like a lot of players wouldn't maybe try
to make the opponent suffer here but big
thing is going to try to make you suffer
maybe one thing I'll just point out that
I was confused about ice I could tell
big Mick was confused about too is big
Mick played a dragon and underrated
opening by the way and here Andriy
osmium plays h3 which seems I'm gonna
say controversial in my limited
understanding of this thing after a
knight c6 Bishop III big m'q takes on e4
and that's kind of your standard trick
that they teach you in school after
which I don't think he has any problems
the weird thing about h3 that I can't
really wrap my head around is in the
game with peril Stein it went like this
peril Stein played an accelerated dragon
and the test for the accelerated dragons
kind of this position here and the
question of what to do after Bishop b3
and what peril Stein does is he goes
Queen a5 and this is a known way to
avoid variations with h4 h5 getting
mated by threatening 94 you kind of
forced castles then in peril Stein play
d6 and then H 3 so this is kind of a
known way for white to play to maybe get
an edge that game was eventually drawn
this though is significantly better for
white than this setup here right cuz
you're just downtime because the it's
not clear that the Queen actually wanted
to be on a 5 so it's almost like he was
repeating this setup and I think
honestly even if black didn't have 94
he's still totally fine but 94 is one of
those liquidating moves asleep well I
guess the game's over now because d5 is
gonna happen
big mcdhh iddin have to play Bishop
before there's other ways of doing it
too and so right we just got this huge
liquidation where black is up a pawn he
gives it back and he's the one to enter
into the white camp first and so black
is gonna white is gonna have to suffer
here but this is
clearly clearly drove but it's good to
see big Mick making the guy suffer right
I believe that big Mick plays a lemur
Andy tomorrow in the final reckoning
assuming you know if this game ends in a
draw then I mean right now I'm really
billing zhabin Andrea seein he's he's a
half point ahead right so mikhalev skis
still at the very top yeah there's gonna
be a lot of interesting games tomorrow
this tournament has been wide open for a
long time I mean Andrea's ian is only up
+2 when you compare Cassata he's up foot
+4 he's up +4 so you know and when you
look at the rest of the field in Group A
there's everybody else's like plus 1 or
minus 1 or minus 2 yeah this is totally
different situation well we've got more
developments in this round but I want to
let everyone know that you can join us
on social media hashtag winter chess
classic and of course us chess champs
calm if you're watching this on youtube
and you want to see the digital board us
chess champs calm is where you want to
go to check it out the YouTube chat
seems to be down right now I'm very sad
about that actually we're just gonna
talk to some of you guys today but who
knows maybe it'll pop back up and if it
does ask your questions and we'll keep
our eye on the chat room ok let's take a
quick glance at the prize fund group a
very generous prize fund $22,000 that 6
grand goes to the champion and in Group
B $14,000 total prize fund and $4,000
will go to the first-place winner and
hey they might have to go through
playoffs to get that money and what we
should really start off with jesse group
b game
eugene peril stein might be in trouble
oh you didn't it's against Lucas ban
forest and this is important for peril
stein who is at the top of the
leaderboard one of the guys at the top
in Group B right right you know I I'm
stay in the same house with Eugene with
a couple of their GM's with milk
mean and stuff and Pearlstein you know
even though he grew up like I did in the
United States totally different chests
education then I had he had all these
top Russian trainers as a kid all this
stuff I was just hearing these stories
today so it's you know so different to
think about our the paths to GM or as I
and most other American kids had it did
it on their by their by themselves peril
Stein had all these amazing coaches
let's take a look
I thought Lucas time forests built up
his position nicely in this position
what I know Carol Stein was going for
when he played c6 is to say that the
bishop on c4 actually just looks good
and we're gonna shut it down with d5 but
watch the way this goes d5 Bishop b3
this is a little clever and the first
tactical point is that if de the Knight
g5 hitting f7 will recapture and will be
doing great
so Bishop g4 at Knight c3 I like it a
lot
what Lucas is saying is since you black
are behind in development you can steal
my pawn here anytime you want you can
you can just have it anytime you want
I'm going to give you multiple chances
to have it and I'm gonna say anytime you
take it my positions gonna open so e 6h
3 the the pawn on d4 is just continually
hanging and because Harrelson has the
chess education I was talking about he's
doing a thing that I don't know if you
remember this but when he won against
team war it was a very similar structure
he gave up his light square Bishop put
all his pawns on light squares and so
you I can tell he was thinking the exact
same thing here but Lucas played a very
nice way a very nice couple moves to
shut down well to make this wall let's
call this the wall here now this wall is
aimed at stopping this Bishop on b3 the
unopposed light square bishop and in a
lot of ways the question of the
the game is can this bishop become
active can the wall somehow being made
weaker and watch what he does Bishop g5
EES doesn't care you can take the pawn
anytime you want on d4 castles rook e1
and this is the clever point is that we
are threatening a tactic with something
like takes and then takes with a pin on
to the Queen that's the tactic we're
threatening and it's so annoying that
peril Stein plays f6 and I know he
didn't want to do that because now this
diagonal and the power of the bishop has
become a little bit more relevant and of
course you don't want to block in your
Bishop on g7 so this was the first sign
of peril Stein having some grief when he
played some nice developing moves and in
this position I think it was fair to say
Lucas has a nice of a reasonable
advantage and what I want you to see is
he's now looking at this diagonal f4 the
bishop is terrible but there's now
problems on the light squares
there he comes this is what we all try
to do we try to trade it all off but
queen h5 very nice and the point is when
you take my knight is free the bishop
and dreaming of coming here this night
is out of play and the dream is you know
we have to get this guy in for us to be
successful if we can either win g5 or
pop it open with h4 he will at least be
doing something 28 king f1 very simple
and strong Knight f3 and this is a
desperation move here c5 Knight g5 and
and ah I don't think my friend Eugene is
gonna live through this one it looks way
too strong too
the since this everything this guy's
gonna collapse if this guy gets active
that's it this guy's out the White King
significantly better than the black King
so a very convincing manner of play from
that forest and kind of from a
preparation sample it's interesting
because Harrelson told me before the
game he's like my strategy is I'm just
whatever he does I'm just gonna play g6
I don't want to face any of his
preparation so and he did he got out he
got a totally original position but he
got outplayed yeah outplayed mostly
because of the development advantage big
news Jesse here in Group A Jeffry Zhang
and Miro have drawn their game which
substantially if I'm thinking correctly
changes the storyline at the very top
with cassada if Quesada draws now he
wins Group A I believe there every
Geoffrey was only at plus one at that
point right at this point so there are
other couple other people at plus one I
mean it's gonna be very hard to catch
casada I think already even before the
revenues is almost impossible the guy
has plus four and the next person had
plus one sauce Kurian I guess would be
the only one right isn't he Elsa plus
one sauce Karen is four out of seven
right now yes plus one yeah so it's easy
he's the only one he's matically yeah
okay now I want to say one thing that's
interesting about this game is Mero has
been playing very conservative chess
just to try to knock it wiped out by
people and to a certain extent work you
know he's lost two games but he has been
even in those games he was you know
essentially I felt holding if you look
what he did in the opening play that
sidelines of the
I guess it's fair to say Jeffrey played
the sidelines here but here we got this
position and he was content to just
suffer here a little bit worse of a
position and yeah this is it's not it's
not sexy or anything like that to play
this way but this is actually the kind
of play you would expect Magnus and Fabi
to be playing as black right this is
what a lot of black players have trained
themselves to do right to sit and suffer
and just take it and then try to play
with the white pieces but we're not
seeing that from so this is like a
vision of what you know top-level chess
used to look like then though I'm
fighting you know with the black pieces
style but it's this is how it looks you
know you suffer a little bit and you
have some small key some small
advantages but a guy has talented as
Geoffrey can't break you down and even
here it looks like Geoffrey has some
chances but look Miro is just like I'm
gonna shut it all down and I'm gonna
trade some stuff off and then what do
you want alright yeah okay so Miro does
it again and Geoffrey let's just say I
mean I was really high on his play in
the first two rounds and even after that
I thought he had a lot of good games he
hasn't been playing badly the key game
in a lot of ways was yesterday's where
he sacked a pawn against Quezada
and I thought he was fine but casados
genius so far this tournament has really
been playing out playing people in a
magnus carlsen kind of way with a slow
easy grind and it's been tough the guy's
been really hard to you know present any
problems with once he gets in the in the
position of just being able to defend so
you don't think about it but right a
defensive player is now the one who's +4
right right
well that's one of his trademarks for
certain yeah let's take a look I
mentioned sassy yeah and let's look at
his game since now it is of immense
importance sassy versus froth milk ooh
meow
in Group A and one thing that's
interesting about this is I mentioned
that the Rosalie mo has a lot of
similarities with the Berlin and this is
a Berlin here and one thing you see here
is that white is technically up to pawns
but the idea whole idea of this opening
for black is to open the bishops and as
you can see they're pretty amazing the
bishops and this pawn is probably gonna
fall someday though not necessarily and
one of these points we can easily
imagine falling to moku means been
thinking a long time on this present
move in fact he's just played rook da
looks sensible to me and then rook e1
happened yeah so I'm anticipating now
that milk cumin is thinking about
something like b4 though there's no rush
to do it I thought it was interesting
one of the things that's been
enlightening to me about milk ooh Mian
it's play in modern chess in general is
he has out prepared all of his opponents
in this tournament and I was watching
the game in the tournament hall earlier
and in this position he played Knight h4
so you know in the Berlin people think
of it as a kind of boring open but I
don't think of it that way I think it's
very rich and interesting and night h4
hasn't been played several times before
saucey wasn't you could tell he wasn't
totally prepared for it and what I meant
to say with the preparation at the
highest levels now is Lukumi ins using a
very powerful computer that he accesses
you know like through the through the
the cloud right right and you know so
back in the day all of us GM's would
just use our normal computer and he's
got access to this supercomputer who's
like doing some deep analysis for him
and so when I watched him sauce II was
thinking here and moku me is just
blitzing out all his moves the f6 he
blitzed out [ __ ] before king f7
blissed-out rook g8 you know so all of
this it's a real bummer when you're
white all of this is already you know
trodden territory for him here and again
it's kind of a trademark of the modern
Berlin players is they're very
comfortable sacrificing a pawn or two as
long as they get their bishops out like
he has here but you know this could
still go either way the pawn on h6 isn't
dead yet and we haven't exactly proven
what we are what we are intending to get
in this position for black notice though
it's very hard to figure out how white
is supposed to improve his position like
how is this terrible night even supposed
to move and what what do you really even
want to do with this part so I believe
in blacks position here but it were at
the stage of the game and we're going to
see this in the Carlsen a match to is
that sure you can have some opening
preparation and you're gonna get some
position that's rich and interesting you
kind of understand it but then you still
have to play move for move you still
have to come up with ideas and this is
tricky this is tricky so we're gonna
keep our eye on that and let's just do a
thought experiment let's say saucey wins
he goes +2 sauce are so the the the
scenario is saucy wins this one and then
tomorrow and then the casada wins losses
today and then tomorrow and then they're
gonna Vienna then they have to do a
playoff well hold on so if so Stassi has
four points right now Kasana
has five and a half right Sassie wins
today Kasana loses yeah casada is still
half point over him right so here the
same thing has to happen the next day
too
right that's how I guess here's well
yeah so so the last round Bowl if if the
same thing happened again
sassy wins casado loses well then sassy
wins out right right yeah yeah yeah okay
so one of the games that is really
interesting positionally then I'm
looking at is group a Moute ela vs.
Robson okay there are two passed pawns
on the e-file and I don't think they can
ever promote this looks crazy what is
going on here Jessie I've been looking
at this game for a while and one thing
we've seen from from modal F who you
know it's really known as a fantastic
attacking player is that he is also
playing he is the example of a guy who
is playing these against these very
cautious efore a 5 games I think
basically all of his white games have
been e4 e5 and then going down some
theoretical line where he clearly
understands the position really well but
it's still so hard to crack and then
what you do is you're gonna get some
position like this where it's your
knowledge of end games and maybe let's
call it subtle tactics this is going to
win the game I have no idea
I have no idea what's going on in
principle I feel like black should be ok
because the pawns although you know nice
they don't seem all that threatening the
time difference is pretty staggering now
the players only have a few more moves
to make until the time control but still
I mean that's right I'm gonna half an
hour you know let's just say the natural
move you know I'm gonna bet I'll just
throw that out there that seems to me
the natural
and then black can think about things
like King g7 f6 but clearly ropes in is
reflecting on what the intentions of
rook d1 are and if there's some trick
involved in rugby one yeah another
really interesting game is this game
with Shimano off against spirits and let
me pull up one position here that I
thought was really interesting this was
one of these 45 games that look like
they're nothing special white plays
Knight a3 I'm sure he could have done
Knight bTW to for example but black says
to himself
okay the knight is on a three away from
the Kings side so that's my cue to ask a
question with the move g5 and g5 is
always going to be controversial in
these positions and always very tactical
and hard to evaluate and one thing
that's interesting the positions are
always a little bit different like if
the knight we're on d2 I think white
would be winning this now after what
asserts did and he played Knight g5 and
one thing about this move is you can't I
don't think you yeah you can't really
calculate it out now it's just gonna be
a long struggle and both sides are still
gonna make mistakes breaking news here
Jesse in Group B Eugene Carroll Stein
has lost as black - Lucas Vaughn forest
so Lucas Vaughn forest looking very good
still one of the top leaders in Group B
and we will see how he can perform
tomorrow yeah maybe we'll even get him
in the studio yeah I'd love to have
Lucas Vaughn forest in here again so
yeah well King g7 Queen f3 who would you
rather be in this position what why do I
feel better is why I mean do you agree
with me well it's funny because the
reason to be suspicious actually of
white is that the knight is way over
here right that's why I was saying if
the knight were closer I could really
imagine
you know the the power being unleashed
upon this pin here which is clearly what
whites on about it's also let's just say
something obvious it's harder to hard to
get a four in because of this guy and
that's really who you need you need to
fit your friend the rook on to the
knight to make black really squirm I
suppose I can't really do anything with
Queen g3 Queen g3 is definitely gonna be
a thought yeah but for example after
rook h8 I think Queen g3 I I might be
able to get away with Knight age five
okay but big struggle here happened I'm
sure mistakes were made on both sides
and in the end black gave the piece back
which I don't think he had to do
nevertheless this position that's arisen
seems very favorable to black at least
on the first glance and the reason is
that my king is gonna get nailed and
this Bishop is still very strong
so my white nice white needs some good
moves right now I guess I assume we're
gonna have to do something like rook e1
and then King runs for the border you
know something like that so I'm a very
interesting game and maybe you know I
didn't analyze it too much but maybe
actually is a sign a good practical sign
from a good practical move by spirits to
give back the piece to get a position
like this where you're at least out of
the bind you know you're not gonna lose
any more okay let's take let's just run
through our other games Robby Kepler's
really can we can answer that for a
second Robby Kamalesh melee versus team
or garea grave it looks like he's about
to be taken out of contention for
consideration of first place I'd saying
groupie
so both the players have made time
control
yeah what's happening here is Griff
gonna lose a piece on h6 it was rook f6
and then king d7 looks like he's gonna
lose a piece I was certain by the way
earlier that garea had a body slam body
slam el macho saw body slam earlier and
how about this I'll just show you this
body slam and you tell me if if you
think it's right
so GF first of all the capitalist Valley
is opening was going I thought fine
until you know I don't know if you
remember this game against Joel where
Joel also played Queen a5 and the Queen
left her man
and this was actually like the moment to
coming up here that was the moment of
truth where after rook f3 I think is a
blunder Griff could have gone off the
top rope here and played f4 it's a very
natural move honestly it's not it
doesn't feel yeah it doesn't feel that
complicated cause you want to look to
see if your Queen can do something over
here by sacking the pawn and the point
is is after Bishop f4 this isn't this is
nasty you can't go back with the rook
because your friend the bishops there
right and if you go this way
oh no Queen d4 and Queen a1 Falls
this is all because the Queen's over
here on adventure and if you take with a
rook then I play Queen h3 I'm hitting
the bishop and the pawn let's say the
Queen comes back
c3 might as well mess with the Queen and
then smack
damn looks miserable looks absolutely
there so this did not happen this didn't
I think yeah this was I'm saying I think
garea really missed a chance here
because more than a body slam this looks
more like a triangle choke armbar pick
your poison company yeah sometimes you
wriggle out of those yeah I didn't know
if there was any wriggling so you know
they continued on big-time pressure hit
and then we got this position and unless
I'm you know losing my mind it looks
like rook g6 takes and takes that looks
like a piece to me right that just looks
like a piece and whites King in addition
is safer so there's not a lot of grief
for white in this position now the two
pawns on a and B are they of concern or
is is white just chill I would be that
concern but you know what check this out
in this position maybe I made anyways he
said no I want to play rook f7 instead
and honestly that's also incredibly evil
because so hurt g6 was a simple way but
Kevlar is really saying you know what
I'm going to snip this pawn I'm and when
I do that I have two threats I'm gonna
hit your Bishop and I just undermined
your rook right
oh so teamwork this is a big chance and
looks like it's gonna go down here after
rook f7 you can't really see their faces
right now in the video but I think we
could all get it on the first guess
which player is team or colors aside
what are those checkered pants man yeah
oh the Hat - you know one thing we know
about trivia is those are the same pants
with which he dropped out of the
airplane oh yeah yeah yeah yeah and then
then yesterday he was also wearing like
the full suit the full checkered suit oh
I'm sorry I missed it yeah very cool
yeah let's run through a couple of these
games also Hawk Obion has just defeated
Joel Benjamin in Group B so a lot of a
lot of decisions coming down the pike
and B Joe was having a real
rough time yet right really rough time
let's look at what happened I thought
Joe was fine the last time I looked you
know they played this opening and Joel
was doing his normal dance I thought he
was fine through all of this let's see
well I take it back in this position
he's no longer fine he's he's suffering
a little bit because the isolated pawn
oh and there it goes he's gonna lose the
pawn and it's pure suffering now Oh
major bummer man the night dance Oh
so Benjamin you know it's really rough
to be listed as an old guy it's rough to
be an old guy and come back and have to
play these kids it's really tough it's
really tough and you know it's really
sad I mean I think too once you start
losing it just gets in your head and
he's had several bad results in a row
and a couple you know like he is play
big Mick and he was totally winning
against big Mick and then big Mick of
course he's a hard guy to actually beat
and he ended up drawing that game it was
one of the many bad you know wasn't
defeat but it was a psychological defeat
for him I wonder what Joe wills it
wonder if Joel had any expectations
coming back to st. Louis for this event
or what they were you know he's a humble
guy I mean I really enjoyed talking to
him before the event but I don't think I
mean in the best possible way I when I
say this I don't think he's a humble guy
oh really
I mean maybe when he talks to you but I
mean maybe you just be nice to no I mean
the guy is a US Champion several times
over he believes in his chess and you
know this is terrible to have to suffer
defeat like this you know right yeah is
one of America's top players yeah
87 97 2003 years he wanted well and one
of those years I think it was 97 he was
the soul champion the other two
a two-way tie than a three-way - uh-huh
right a three-way tie for the US
Championship how could they how dare
they can we look at big Mick because he
yes might be look looking to come off
the rope here haha let's will we left it
it was something like this and it looked
like I'm sure
Andrea's Ian believed that this was
going to be hold a bowl with no problems
and it should be but right around here
things start getting weird GF h for
rookie seven and known as big Mick isn't
even taking that pawn on before this
pawn by the way to big Mick for a guy
like big make that pause just a
spectator it's not a real pawn because
we can take it anytime big Mick says
check to the miserable King rook f3 King
g2 and big Mick says alright I'll take
on f4 and I mean come on it has to still
via draw but this is what I mean by big
Mick he's gonna keep playing and playing
and playing right and Riaz ian is now
looking to play rook f3 next and yeah it
should be a draw but this what I'm
saying you know about big Mick he's
never gonna give up
alright that would of course really
shake things up if big Mick were to
somehow win this thing well no doubt yes
and and people who follow this event are
pretty familiar with big Mick know the
winner of Group B before actually back
in the summer classic and we've really
taken a liking to him and he is someone
who will keep playing he won't really
love what else okay here a group a key
matchups Evian cassada what has changed
here so yeah let's go through it this
was where we left it black activates the
king
and yeah this is all textbook stuff
we're gonna knock you know we're gonna
control c5 and we're gonna bring our
Knight over there so the bishop is gonna
have a hard time controlling mr. Knight
who's running around and you know for a
guy like me it feels like it should be a
torture situation for casada you know
the guy's interesting he he might
whether right or wrong I think his
attitude is just like I'm fine I think
it might be the wrong attitude but I
think that's his attitude here it is
dangerous you know that the knight gets
to dance around it on all the colors
this is a dogmatic but very important
statement the knight gets the dance
around on all the colors and the black
bishop only ever gets to talk to 32
squares right yeah so like that pawn on
a seven on a c6 all those squares in the
Kings side whereas white just needs to
control g3 there's no cat though no real
counter play here right so I still like
Samuels position and that would be a big
win for him he hasn't had the most luck
let's call it that way in this
tournament let's check out sh'mon off
and while you do that are one of our top
performers in Group B with his victory
today Lucas van forest is ready for an
interview so I'll bring him in great
yeah while he's coming in I'll show you
guys this game with Shimano and see if
there's any chance for him surviving
here Brooke aged 5 we left it somewhere
around here
Rick fe1 is predicted and black doesn't
even take the pawn on g5 instead says
I'll do it this way and let's think
about this position
black is obviously up upon but what
Shimano has done well for himself is
that he now at least has a little bit of
counter play against the black King so
maybe maybe Shimano can hold on to this
if black wants it looks like he can
always do Queen c1 and Queen f4 alright
I have Lucas net force in the studio
with us who is now at Whittier plus two
bump well that's what all right very
nice game today even though you're
playing my friend and you know the guy
who lives across the hall from me let's
go through this one thing I was telling
the fans is rightly or wrongly he was
kind of didn't want to face any of your
preparations so he's just like I'm gonna
play g6 yeah you got an original game
yeah it's actually the move that I have
a very bad score against the only move I
score below 50% so it's a logical
decision
sure so now did you know I did not
prepare this just yeah do you just
played it normally I play with c3 very
solid stuff but like it's normal
advantage probably for white and he
probably prepared some stuff huh so I
thought I would go for something new he
probably doesn't know a lot too so so
you'd seen this somewhere before
yeah I knew it was an opening with it
yeah that was about it it's I I actually
remember flirting around with this you
know when I when I had my malaise and
tried to play e4 which is a big mistake
but you know I think what his reaction
was no you can't actually put the bishop
there because I'm just gonna hit you
yeah right but but it's not so simple no
I mean in the main line is just Knight
f6 Queen e2 cos oh and this is supposed
to be fine for blood right and it's yeah
I was not sure like I feel I should be
better here
I mean Bishop g4 is logical he just
wants to like close to structure and
claim that he has exchanged his bad
bishop right and I don't know if you
remember the game that peril Stein had
against teamwork
where it was almost a very similar
structure he changed it off the light
scraping on plate ecigs and put all his
pawns on light squares so I had think
that was probably going through his mind
when he played Bishop g4 here but it's
yeah it seems positionally good but
actually it's really risky like if let's
say he puts all all of his pawns on
white the Josh cross can get very weak
yeah of course
now let's just say for the fans out here
that well let me let me do two moves
here couple moves actually and look at
this position I would I really admired
that you just let the d4 pawn hang all
the time there's like it's been hanging
for a while yeah but it's it's not hang
okay it's hanging but if he takes on d4
I will take on d5 right and I will just
put a knight on d5 sacrifice it done
yeah no I thought this was great because
you're you really need to keep the
center fluid right yeah I wanted to yeah
yeah yeah yeah so I don't need to like I
could also play with E 5 like maybe 93
wasn't the best move what he said it's
just 92 and c3 maybe but I wanted to
keep the center somewhat open right
there so that's okay after Bishop eres
on development advantage it so I started
this for a while because I thought at
first when I was up there I was like god
maybe Eugene got what he wanted here
mm-hmm but on the other hand you were
able to create very quick problems after
his natural move with 97 mm-hmm and then
I thought on night at 6 I assumed Bishop
g5 yeah yeah it's been his relief and
then if he can make I was thinking like
if he can make if you can make his white
pawns move in any way right then your
bishop will then come alive yeah and
that seemed like your whole strategy
which works out because after a 97
Bishop g5 castles rook e1 he has to do
something yeah yes we'll make this f6
weakness because I'm just trying to take
on d5 right and Knight takes d5 and I
thought here yeah you were better now
yeah it's clear that you're better I
thought for like a few minutes I was
just winning
I mean I thought I'd miss a parent more
space and his position is full of
weaknesses but actually the position is
not that easy because my bishop on b3 is
not really placed perfectly the knight
on c3 is actually not doing that much
and if he is able to just keep this
solid then and it's not so easy for me
to proceed I think this is the dream
though this is yeah I was happy
oh yeah maybe Bishop f4 I don't know
yeah Bishop f4 maybe better I should
have actually won for that but okay
Bishop h4i this is a very sad night
placement I don't know where that guys
going yeah well it's going to c7
it wants to go to c7 and if it goes to
d7 uh-huh I've queen g4 so here's
already a point I guess where you should
have played bishop there a reason to
play Bishop f4 because here you're
playing Bishop g3 right yeah so it was
probably and people right but just
orientation and then you do an
interesting thing here comes about 92
yeah so I was just thinking that okay I
have two pieces that are no place
perfectly the bishop on b3 and an item
c3 so I will just reroute tomorrow night
to d3 and C 3 V sub C 2 so that's just
the plan and yeah because these are just
my only two bad pieces right and here I
thought you were dreaming about maybe
takes and c4 maybe c4 hi Ali
yeah it's actually maybe it's a plan
here because what after what he did it's
probably not that great although it's
possible yeah so g5 let's just say he's
trying to get some space for a night but
really controversial because now the
light squares are open yeah he's just
he's weakening his pawn structure but
his pieces are somewhat coming alive so
I I expected this move looks normal
right I think I'm better for sure and
you know maybe there's something you
know the computer would find something
better
you did but night see one yeah well you
know actually one of the funniest things
at the tournament for me was we were
talking in the in the blitz room up in
the skittles room upstairs and you you
said this thing like you're imitating us
old guys doing ah these young kids today
all they can do is calculate and I see
one that's a nice positional move the
night needs to get fixed
yeah yeah he needs to get fixed okay
yeah
first place f5 yet otherwise yeah he
just needs some conquer play yeah calm
move and this is nice too because see
for you could have done c4 to but it's
really the weaknesses on this diagonal
that are you see right yeah that's what
I'm aiming for and then I end up be v
square is really key and so it's like
this move feels right because he's gonna
block your vision you know but that it
really is now the Gateway yeah are your
bishop well that's I think it's the best
move because otherwise I go Bishop e5
myself and now he at least has something
because this Bishop on 8-hd was out of
play mm-hmm but my LightSquared bishop
is really starting to get them to play
here and here he does the thing that
I've seen casada do in this tournament
and I've seen Miro doing this tournament
and that is let's trade off all the
rooks yeah I didn't like this at all
I thought it was just winning here yeah
what do you think you should do
yeah okay I think I'm better anyways
like but maybe ninety-seven because this
is the only piece that isn't really
playing and then just getting it into
two to three six
I assume queen h5 a queen h5 and mighty
six and let's say I go h4 you will just
take it and with GG takes h4 oh and here
Ruki - maybe f3 so the position is not
that clear okay I'm better of course but
from right
maybe Bishop you want if it's working
bishop yeah you have a lot yeah well is
there a thing in Dutch called a luxury
choice ah yeah yeah yeah how do you how
do you say I'm trying to learn new words
you're Dutch do right mind last name
stuff you know but that's like my
grandfather ah a long time ago and he
wasn't even Dutch himself is just like a
Dutch community here in America
I had to settlers yeah well there's
nothing like one board which you can say
like this a sentence or something okay
it's not something special
anyway it's you know we we don't have
that word so I'm trying to bring it and
bring it into English the luxury choice
ah okay yeah but I kind of come up it is
it's very okay so he trades off all the
rooks and you just say okay Queen each
five you know and now unfortunately he's
really gonna help your pieces here by
taking on you one yeah and yeah just how
much so now my Knights can maybe come to
f3 and my bishop is playing so yeah I
thought it was just over here one thing
it's always satisfying for an old guy
like me is when you have the plan of the
unopposed bishop that begins really once
you get this position so I moved nine
mm-hmm right and black is like no I'm
gonna build the wall and then all of a
sudden you know many many moves later
we're gonna get this position yeah and
it's just like oh where did it all go
yeah it's really a drag like hospital
said that even the worst bishop is
better than the best night that's right
yeah because what at some point this
bishop is getting into play and it's
just much better than another night or
anything and I'm just gonna assume that
that's lost here yeah
c5 it was just a desperate attempt it's
logical but you're never defending you
have too many weaknesses on the
queenside g5 sweet g6 this week i will
come at age four or g3 and my king is
just totally say five and your bishops
gonna come back out yeah yeah and that's
just that's an answer yeah yeah that was
his only trump yeah that's the only
thing he have and it's quite important I
mean if I don't get it in a plate and
you have something playful but here okay
so far all right well great game and you
know I think you let's let's just have
let's just while you're here let's take
a look at the Michalowski game it seems
like it's got to be a pushing but he's
always pushed a big label always pushed
so let's assume that's a draw and Andre
Ossian will be plus two and you've got
plus one so you still have a shot at it
tomorrow yeah actually for me it doesn't
matter who wins because if Michael SP
wins see some plus two that's true but
it seems like he can really try here
with two it's not winning but yeah he's
gonna he's gonna make him suffer
yeah yeah just like Carlsen becomes
Kohana you know window in the first game
yeah yeah yeah just seven no not today I
thought Carlson was really gonna push
him today we did yeah but it was to draw
too much towards the end don't you think
that was like some chances there yeah
okay but you Bobby you smelled that back
okay hold on hold on let me show you the
position because now we got you here
so though I didn't watch the the end so
maybe there's like this position yeah
this is what he got and I was like oh I
don't know there's a lot of ideas here
with f4 yeah g5 sometime I thought this
was like a dream for Carlsen yeah this
is what yeah big Mick had this position
he would have beat Bobby like you're
missing pieces to attack like if you
would put some pair of roots on it you
would of course it'd be nice I can't
have everything
no but here the problem is just that Y
doesn't have any weaknesses right well
but imagine when f4 comes mm-hmm it's
gonna be there's gonna be some problems
but then only five can be comon weak
through like yeah of course of course
but anyways in the game it kind of
petered out after this and then and then
there turned out there really wasn't
much you know you just know you just sat
on the position you do have a bishop
yeah well good luck tomorrow thank you
for coming down and don't forget we're
early around tomorrow is all ours yeah
alright
okay thanks thank you we're gonna go to
a break
a moment comes in chess when you need to
test yourself at a different level chess
24 premium offers the tools that you
need to reach your maximum potential
from hundreds of interactive video
lessons to becoming part of the chess 24
community you can analyze with friends
or coach your students live you get
twenty four by seven coverage of chess
news and events access to premium
analysis and commentary and the chance
to interact with grandmasters and other
top players and coaches get it bashed
for the best and even challenge them to
a battle be the best chess player you
can be it's time to level up your game
with just 24 Premium Membership
[Music]
[Music]
hello and welcome back to round 8 of the
2018 winter chess classic my name is Ben
Simon and here with Grandmaster el macho
Jesse cry we're here calling the action
going into the final stretch of this
event now all but one of the games are
over in Group B and we are guaranteed to
go and see who the winner of the field
will be tomorrow but chances still exist
for this thing to be clinched in Group A
so let's start with our key matchup in
Group A Quesada's game against Sam 7-7
is white right and as we left it I was
saying that it seemed like black should
be suffering it still seems like the
case but as I said then casada is not
afraid of a slightly worse position this
one would make me personally afraid
they've just exchanged these pawns on g5
and it looks like FG is also going to
happen and so the problem for white
really in executing the weaknesses here
is it'd be nice that if my king could
get active and didn't have to babysit
this pawn g3 but even so the Knights
gonna start dancing in particular we're
gonna see a move like Knight c8 and once
this pawn comes 286 then I can come back
around and maybe come tonight c5 amongst
other squares where you know if the pawn
falls that's it so yeah very dangerous
position in my view for cathodic but as
I said before kisana
he doesn't mind he doesn't mind it
doesn't have a lot of the same fears
that other people have and that's
probably why he's at blessed for in this
event yeah Samuels thinking about f g5 I
don't know maybe mildly considering f5
but that would truly be a weird attempt
yeah so he took the pawn
and we're gonna get King takes g5 and
then we're gonna see if Samuels able to
put some pressure on the natural move is
Knight c8 but then you know I'm sure
Samuels thought about that and then
thinking about how it look after that
let's just play a couple natural moves
and see what happens tonight c8 a
six-night b6 well yeah and so I'm I'm
really threatening to go in what
probably is a winning pawn endgame
because these guys are outside passed
pawns so let's say you run for the
border Knight a4 and you read a route
you better run back now but it's not so
easy in fact there's no way to run back
if you run back Bishop e4 Knight c5 you
can't even get to Bishop b3 so this is
the kind of grief I'm talking about
Knight c8 is on the board it's hard to
imagine a different way you got to play
a six right and that's what happened and
right Knight b6 looks pretty it's
definitely there might be something
fancier but that's gonna put real
question marks on to the position here's
an idea that was better than the last
variation anyway for Black Knight b6
Bishop b3 and there's gonna be more than
one move for white but let's just look
at 97 and now you can always play Bishop
c4 in response to Knight c5 but some
definite grief and one several thoughts
here for black for white is like if I
get my knight on e5 I could actually
prevent you from coming to g4 and then
play King III king d4 so Knight b6 is on
the board and here we go if you're an
old man what you've probably done is
you've graduated from studying openings
to studying endgame studies and this is
really starting to look like an endgame
study where the knight could do some
serious domination against the bishop
it's not actually a lot of beginners
when they see the bishop they're like I
want the pawns in the same color as the
bishops
that they can protect the pawns but it's
really a bummer because now they're in
the way of the bishop and Samuel I think
should be able to do several ideas here
which will make the black suffer and the
first thing he does he just steps away
from the board because black is now the
one who's really gonna have to go into a
deep think to think about how to save
the game
he cannot prevent the knight coming from
c2 c5 though for example on Bishop e6 BC
BC Bishop b3 there's 97 and I'm Bishop
e6 I can go to Knight a 4 now that
doesn't mean to say that like the bishop
you know well that night c5 is
necessarily the knockout blow there
might be even other ideas for for white
and that's just the general dilemma for
for black now there's so many different
things that white can do with the knight
and black is going to be kind of in a
static holding pattern my own chess
sensibilities would be rewarded if
casada lost not to because I want casada
to lose or anything but just because it
seems like he gets away with stuff like
especially the game against Jomon off
the thing he got away with there I
looked at him with both of the players
afterwards and it did the fact that he
felt no danger I was like you can't do
it so visually 6 was played and as I
said before Knight a 4 is the natural
move but I wouldn't wouldn't surprise me
if there's another one one reason that I
can imagine Bishop e6 being better than
Bishop b3 is that I'm Bishop b3 let's
say Knight d7 in addition to threatening
Knight c5 there was that variation
Knight e5 at some point which also which
really might be good to stop the counter
play of the King coming to g4 and that
would allow me to maybe do something
like King III d4 so very promising
position we'll come back in a little bit
now I'm going to show you a position I
really don't understand
and this is the ropes in position where
it's equal material black one that the
annoying pawn on e6 but in a way that
might have been a good thing for Moda
left because now at least the rook on e3
is communicating with the pawn on e7 and
ropes and is saying my rook on d6 is
creating a very annoying pin against the
knight on d4 another move he could have
done it's some kind of rook f7 business
but rook d6 why not that looks annoying
and a simple threat that he's created
now is rook d4 followed by Knight f5 and
yeah so actually maybe ropes and has a
little something-something there
I even mowed a left push too hard which
can often happen right in these
positions where you're really going for
it I would rather have black in this
situation I mean yeah the just because
at the very least the G and the H pawns
are together the F in the H are not for
white right I mean nothing's gonna
become of the e pawn right well black
hopes but it's also true like black at
some point to this is a pretty simple
move to make right that's gonna be
coming I might just scoop it up you know
I'm with you I think the more you look
at it's like well and now that but white
has some just sincere tactical problems
with this knight on d4 yeah
because Knight f5 I don't know how you
stop it I'm gonna guess that rook d6 was
the move that modal F overlooked and
we're just out of time pressure here so
that could have been you know something
that wasn't on his horizon all right
let's take a look most of our games in
Group B are over
except mikhalev ski and one thing that
man Forest said that was interesting to
me
said with the two rooks this will be
hard for white and it's an interesting
comment because if we took a pair of
rooks off and as just to remind everyone
the pawn on b6 is dead
the pawn on d6 is just a distraction big
mitt can come and take that one everyone
once but what Lucas was meaning was well
okay with the one rook on then it would
be probably a fairly easy well be a
fairly easy hold for white but with two
rooks on it just gives black more
possibilities to do stuff but so we got
to ask well what exactly is it that you
want to do because it's not even so
clear like what the threat is imagine
the b6 pawn is gone how do you actually
create a threat and you know big Mick
he'll come up with something I thought I
faced this guy you think you're out of
the trouble and yet he'll keep coming so
and already we've seen that in this game
in position several you know ten moves
ago I don't think anyone would have
guessed that it would look this bad for
what so a key matchup that we'll
continue looking at but I mean it would
it be who Victor to play g5 at some
point you can play g5 and then then what
g4 I guess is your dream right right at
some point we might do that I think
there's an interesting game of
cat-and-mouse going on with this rook
here for example like rook ce6 would be
a kind of a normal-looking move maybe
let's just put that on the board to
think about it and I'm sure it's
playable but this I think he's worried
about the victors were coming back to c3
and you see it still it's kind of hard
to move mm-hmm right you if you place a
move this rook then this is check to the
miserable King and then that's really
annoying right and we're still gonna
maybe do that rook check b7 was played
so basically Andre Aussie and is saying
big Mick I want you to dislocate your B
to rook away from my King and maybe even
he's dreaming of some kind of counter
play after a big Mick takes the thing of
course big Mick he said no a the barn is
still a spectator in this position
there's no rest for us to actually go
and take it
what one reason to maybe actually take
it though is if you don't do it right
away and you play some other move white
could play rook e7 and then at some
point you really will have to take it
and then we're gonna go into that rook
end game with just rooks instead of two
rooks so let's say yeah let's say rook
d7 the question white should be asking
himself is what is the danger right what
is the danger and your move of some kind
some kind of g5 g for at some point is
probably the most dangerous thing that
black has white has to worry about but
even maybe even like an f4 f3 with a
check coming on g5 situation that's
might be an example of something
terrible that might happen to you even
that I'm not sure is I'm not sure that
really does D take it's hard for the
black King to get involved right it's
hard for him to get involved yeah so
we'll come back and look at that and
that's our last game in Group B
well and I've got the chat open you got
the chat the YouTube chat alright
finally and Marcin wants to know how is
Darla spirits doing let's listen good
game good question we're just looking at
that and it's been a real slugfest I'm
sure daro feels like he should have won
long ago but here we are white has
survived at least at this point and
black is definitely still has some
practical chances the bishops of
opposite colors simply mean that the
initiative now is going to be a bigger
deal if the Queen's came off then you
really would have the classical bishops
of opposite color like draw cliche going
on it wouldn't be that hard but here
there's you know mating attempts for
black and black needs to both give white
some grief and secure his own king right
from checks for example if you played
King g5 some kind of check on g8 is
probably just going to end and it's just
gonna create an immediate draw because
we trade trade everything off
you know White has to worry about Queen
g1 check for example but let's just see
on example Queens you one check King h3
this queen is very well centralized
hitting this nice square here which is
going to make it difficult for black to
do anything and of course if the White
Queen strays too far Queen f5 is
obviously on the agenda so this is
Darrow's big moment to see if he can
find some kind of trickiness in the
position maybe maybe he can you know
it's it is gonna be tough though
it seems like white always has enough
for harassment of the black King maybe a
nice idea could be checked to the
miserable King King g2 and then I move
like c6
so I'm protecting this square so there's
no check there and the idea of c6 is
that I might want to bring the bishop
back so you know let just for kicks let
me just show check to the miserable King
if King H do I have the option now this
should be 8 it's like another option
that I have for myself that would just
be useful so that's my with my first
instinct though I'm sure dar was really
thinking about now they're out of time
pressure and so yeah I thank the caller
for the question because yeah I think
there's a little bit of massage left
that might be technically drawn but this
is gonna be some massage material right
here
Sassy's game yeah this is very important
it may be keep in mind if sassy doesn't
score better than quesada does then
Kasana wins the field today the way it's
going right now it looks like Quesada is
gonna win the field today it looks like
both games might be headed to draws am I
correct in saying that what do you think
well I'd say what I still believe that
Sam has a nice position but in this
position here this looks like it's hard
to imagine this not being a draw because
no clue Miam can at any point play f4
cut the bishop from the pawn and then
snip the thing now maybe there's some
practical chances in a move like Bishop
c5 but even that I don't believe like I
think I can I think I can just take the
thing even like like take
because I run this guy and you have to
come and then I take this you know we're
onto that journey yeah it may be even
that's a little complicated but those
are the kinds of things that they're
thinking about now it seems to me like
moku Mian can hold this without we
should be able to hold this without too
much grief because imagine even if on
Bishop c5 you have to go back you know
still I don't really hard to imagine how
you're ever gonna to win this thing if
you have to babysit the pawn from this
side you just control so many so much
fewer squares than you did from the
other side right where you're gonna get
knocked off up with that foursome but
that's what they're thinking about let's
take a look at that game that we were
just referencing the casada game and
look at how it went down so 94 Bishop c4
and Knight c5 was definitely a thing but
you know one thing about this is you you
can kit the knight to c5 I think without
too much trouble
92 happens notice that it's impossible
for casada to dominate the night because
the unfortunate a4 actually traps the
bishop and what's nice to understand
about that tactic is that the pawns on
a6 and c6 aren't really black's friend
because they are blocking the bishop
from coming back and they are overdoing
it on the light squares and what I mean
by that overdoing it is is that if we
can put like a knight here which would
prevent or somewhere would prevent the
King from coming over we have an oak we
own those dark squares coming into the
c5 square so Bishop d5 happened and yeah
very pleasant position for Samuel to do
things like night d1 III or some kind of
he's looking for some kind of maneuver
like that where yeah a lot of nice
maneuvers another one to think about is
the simple 93 that would be for sure a
good practical move where
you have to worry again about 95 but
also this 95 thing and as I said the
ideas put the night on some square where
it prevents this King from coming in and
we then bring our guy in so very
unpleasant for black yeah now our cop my
co commentator sometimes looks at the
computer evaluation I never look you
know maybe before the game my glance
just by accident or whatever but I never
look and I took by his tone he was like
oh it's headed for a draw so maybe he
knows the computer saying it's a draw
but that would honestly be it'd be
misleading because even if the computer
said that from a human standpoint this
is still black giving black is the one
who can make an error here I don't think
white can ever lose this Ray's game
let's see if modal F was able to come up
with something in 76
he played rookie 5 so this stops our
Knight f5 move and ropes in place king
f7
so let's ask an obvious question what
would happen after rook g5
I'm assuming the seat on rookie 7
there's an unfortunate problem
and his name is rook g7 King and Knight
f5 so you know rookie five is a good
resource but what how are we gonna do
after rook takes g5 I'm well there's a
simple way out of it and that is to play
no there isn't
I was gonna say king of steaks is a
simple way out of it but you just plays
rook g7 hello that doesn't work so what
g5 has not yet been played this is our
question here about how rope soon will
continue I believe very much in blacks
position so I'm not
I'm sure he's able to find something
here Knight d6 is maybe something that
modal F is worried about on not taking
on g5 immediately
that looks annoying anyway
yeah that looks kind of annoying no that
was been our pin and win strategy for
quite some time here on this thing right
so modal F thinking about it and it
still looks like ropes and is the one as
you said you'd rather be black here yeah
yeah you see that though when you're
playing a strong player then they play
rook e5 and then you start thinking
yourself yeah maybe I'm not as maybe I'm
not a genius you know maybe I'm not the
the next Boy Wonder it's happened to all
of us okay so Sam put his knight on d3
King f5 alright so here's some
interesting problems for Sam to solve we
would love to play King III but if we do
King g4 is just gonna come right back at
us hold on yeah let's get the moves back
up on the screen there we go oh yeah so
I was just talking 93 is on the board
then King f5 and if King III which we'd
like to do the problem is King g4 so
that's the you know potential counter
play that seve on has to somehow take
care of before his King goes on a
journey and he also doesn't really want
the King to come in so for example
Knight c5 is an obvious thought pawn
must be defended and let's see if we can
work some magic here
let's try ok Knight c5 did happen I'm
assuming Bishop c4 is going to come
and King e3 let's just try it out I
don't think it actually works it but
let's just try it out it might be
instructed King g4 and yeah it's not
it's not so easy for example King D for
and just even Bishop II 1 e 2 or ef-1
and there's no easy way for the King to
come back no I did correctly predict
some stuff white did play King III and
one cool thing about King III is you
don't necessarily have to calculate King
g4 King D for you because what you do
know is that on King g4 you can always
go back to f2 and casada is the guy
who's got to figure out if you know
there's some trick with King g4 King D
for my sense is that there isn't but I'm
not quite sure about that another thing
that white can always do if he wants is
he can improve the position of his pawns
so like a four a five let's go ahead and
look to see if there's magic after King
g4 what I mean by magic is if we can say
run the Bishop out of squares on that
diagonal in some way right or create
some forking potential with an with the
poor King
if it is possible it's definitely not
easy let's try 94 here's a nice
variation is that if F 596 just for
kicks let me show King G 3 Knight f5
King G for this would be precisely the
situation that I think is going to be
lost for white because our King is going
to be better and the work yeah work our
King is invading it is invading over
here and it should be lost well is that
the best path for black I mean no no it
isn't I'm just showing as an example if
we can get so what it shows kind of is
if we keep the King on the King side
Plus when the F pawn this is kind of
what we're aiming for right so let's go
King III is the positioning casada is
wondering about king g4 it's hard for
black that you because he has another
option he didn't think about king e5 and
honestly maybe that's the most sensible
but remember the idea but for black
would be well if I play King g4 and he
has to play King f2 then it's looking
pretty dry right away right so let's
look again at King g4 I said 94
yeah this is in so an example of
trickery would be on Bishop d5 but
unfortunately for white this does not
win this endgame does not win with
Knight takes because it's black who's
coming in black is coming with a check
so that doesn't work so if we play you
know if King g4 94 we need a solution to
Bishop d5 here's a nasty trick here here
and a four
no that's not a nasty trick I always
think I played b5 worst case scenario
black just takes it all yes so that's
not it
but yeah so actually this is it's close
it's real close in addition though what
I guess the other question is this like
well what would the other move besides
94 be if black chooses kingi for this is
some of the things that casada is
thinking about right now
one bummer for white is that on 97
kingi 395 Bishop d5 does hold everything
intact but you can feel right that this
Knight is dreaming of some really
delicate maneuvers of King G for some
really dangerous stuff could happen
that's it again at 94 by the way some
people find this kind of stuff really
boring but once you cross age 40 this is
all you got left this is the dream yeah
it's a good time in addition you know
maybe it's as you're saying with Lucas
dead forest it's a luxury question is
maybe black could also play King G 5
there's really no luxury for this for
what black because he's gonna suffer in
both ways
if King e5 I don't have to worry about
the Jeep horn anymore and you know the
knight what the knight can do with the
King has really shove him out of certain
square so I should be able to shove you
out of king e5 and then you have to
worry about King V for king g4 did
happen
let me just show a problem with kini 5
for example Knight d7 if candy 596 loses
that's a magic and if king d6 I'm gonna
assume King V 4 wins
I'm just yeah that's got to be winning
for example sniped
snippin I'm gonna run you out of moves
right because I can I don't even have to
do pawn moves I can do when was a king
before and then I'm coming him yeah so
king g4 happened and now it's Samuels
big moment to calculate whether he can
find a way to make a move like 94 work
or if he's just gonna go back it doesn't
necessarily mean the game's over if he
goes back I assume you know King f5
might be the the best move anyway but
yeah I like for example you could play
this position and now try King f3 and
then try your luck that way because any
time he plays Bishop e5 he's gonna have
to go back to babysit the pawn right so
one intention for black might be to say
well I'm just gonna trade everything off
with f5 but actually I think that's
terrible because now 97 f4 will lose 295
right
the knight is a tricky piece so the good
news for Savion is King f2 even though
it looks like not a very forceful move
still very much holds chances to win
this game and and then you know you get
the luxury of also thinking about 94 or
some other tricky business
yeah all right let's see if ropes and
cracked him and I want to let you all
know that we are staying overtime today
typically now is the time when we would
end our abbreviated broadcast but
because there is a potential game or
field clinching situation in Group A we
are going to stay on until we have a
resolution right and right here it looks
like um well ropes indefinitely is for
choice here he's the e7 pawn is going to
fall and Robson has a variety of
different ways to make that
and that happened and he might even be
interested in bigger fish than this then
this pawn on e7 because that night is
still pinned you know and it's not so
easy to get out of it one variation for
example is pawn takes let's just say
let's just call this the pawn green
variation rook takes and luckily for for
black this there's no Knight f5 check
because we can wear our knight is doing
at least one job there
this would allow white to break the pin
but so what you're just gonna come over
me so rookie said we don't have to
really worry about this would be a way
to play four ropes and that's free of
any worry the intention of modal if I
assume is actually this snip-snip and
now king e5 so there's no nasty check
and you can't intensify the pressure on
my knight because now I have Knight f5
this is actually it seems like good
counter play at least on first glance
because we're threatening things like
rook g1 of course the game black could
play rook g6 and make the game go longer
so that's let's call that the default
that rope sim can go to like the minimum
he can get and this is a position he's
just wondering if you can get more than
that in this position you have there's
something more special than that
continuation
all right look one of the games we
haven't looked at and why let's see if
there's anything in groupies final game
of the day between Andrea Siena and Big
Mac sure the last time we looked at it
we were like well what is big mix plan
here
yeah have things changed for you well my
move wasn't played but the king is is
advancing on black side well let's say
the obvious thing that's happened is
that the rooks have been traded and in
general it's for the general the three
versus two is never going to be a win
and I don't even see how big Mick can
make think make life rough here for
black I assume he's going to try
something now like king f4 + g5 g4 but
even if I give you all those moves you
still haven't done it yet alright but
okay yeah big mix gonna big mix gonna
make it go with it yeah yeah it's it is
unfortunately for big makers just not
enough juice to make this really
dangerous I think but we'll keep an eye
because you know big Mick he'll hurt you
he'll come out your knee you can see
he's still pressing and pressing here so
in Group A we have a couple games left
saw C is trying to make this work now I
left it and maybe I was wrong when I
said that black had an easy draw but
let's just take a look at how this went
so it was King h7 I believe King C for
Bishop III Bishop c5 Bishop g3 and
Bishop f8 so because f4 was a problem
the bishop has to go babysit the pawn on
the other side but the general grief
about that is that the bishop has far
less scope right it can only go between
f8 and g7 the whole while and what does
white need to do he'd love to win the
pawn on c6 but the problem is is that
Bishop you want us
let's let's figure this out actually so
Bishop II 1 what would happen if King c5
this is this is kind of interesting
I think what would happen is f4 snip f3
Bishop c5 Bishop b4
that looks like the general problem that
blacks facing and of course the white
bishop could not take the black one
because then the f-con is promoting
right in that situation and so in this
in this position after Bishop e1 saucey
played king d4 presumably to guard
against just that but let's just check
that variation encompassone on if f4 the
danger is you're going to lose that
point but imagine like no this is not
true you're you're gonna run to the
border here right you're running to the
border
yeah no way you're gonna win this now
right I just hang out and the bishop if
it moves away I snipped the pond for
example Bishop c5 snip snip and snap
so king d4 was attempted and I suppose
the dream is to play King he five yeah
okay it's a good dream
saucy just says okay King g8 what do you
got Bishop d6 and now the easy move to
play is king h7 back because the bishop
has to is babysitting both the b4 and
the h6 lon
right so he's got to play to f8 you'd
love to be back here again but
unfortunately there's no real way to do
it
Oh a ladies like those arrows look at
that and that nice live arrow rely there
about that spirits and sh'mon off
something interesting happened here I
don't think I understand it let's see it
went so this is where we left he said
check to the misérable king king h1 and
now this very tricky looking move Bishop
c5 well I like it that's I think I like
it I think I understand it so before we
look at the tactics the idea is similar
to d6 system I move c6 only that now he
would like to put the bishop to have the
option to put the bishop here so that we
have this diagonal now the obvious
question which I'm sure Shimano F is now
partnering is what happens if I just
take this guy right
and you're gonna lose the bishop either
to Queen h3 or to Queen the one and
there's gonna be questions about what it
then looks like so let's just there
might be better than Queen d1 but let's
just put that on the board might be
better than we might change our minds
about g2 but let's put that on the board
too let's say let's say check and just
pretend he has to go back Queen c7 right
and then it's pretty nasty you check and
you pick up this point and as long as
there is no perpetual check from white
in these kinds of endings the past pawn
is totally brutal in the Queen and pawn
the Queen endings you know it's funny a
lot of people have this notion of most
endings being kind of dross and that
comes from Brooke endings which we have
more work endings than anything else but
Queen endings are vicious they are
absolutely vicious who has the
centralized Queen and who has the
passport the past pawn is what the Queen
endings are made of you can have a lot
of extra points but just what extra
fastball and the Queen ending is usually
what decides it so Bishop c5 a very nice
move if at least a very creative attempt
by daro to to create some drama here and
Queen h3 mate is the threat oh my
goodness yeah if you if you play king h2
I think we're gonna also say that this
is grief let's just look at it for a
second Bishop d6 King h1 check to the
misérable King
and on kingi one i think there are
several moves but just imagine I can
also I can force you back into the [ __ ]
I can force you to take it this time
with Bishop c5 so nice move from daro I
don't see any clean way for Shimano to
or what's going I don't see any path for
clean equality for Shimano if here this
is suffering all right now let's look at
what happened I love this position so
King G for King f2 King f5 and now the
simple a4 we thought that might be
coming king e5 King III well I think
well here it is we've achieved something
you know we're we've got it and we're
coming on with a 4 a 4 is not only
closer to the other side of the board
but a lot of times when we're gonna try
to attempt to run the bishops out of
Bishop out of squares it's nice to
control b5 so as predicted I think this
is rough I think it is now getting
concrete and the simple threat on the
board now is 97 where the king is going
to be kicked out of Dodge really like
let me just put on f6 that six is not a
good move let's just pretend white can't
take it either right King d5 loses
Knight b6 right and a king d6 will allow
me to play a move like Knight b6 and all
I need is for the bishop to move for me
to have the time to bring my king in
right in the game King d5 was played
okay so then big the natural question is
does does 97 do it does 97 do it and
maybe Bishop b3 is what you neski is
casada is counting on it looks it looks
real dangerous real dangerous Knight b6
King e5 and let's let's head on over
there's more than one way for white to
play but you know these simple
variations show how difficult it is for
the guy let's look at this again man
watch you play a move or two for from
let's think about it so the idea of King
d5 would be like maybe we move this
Bishop and then play King's c4 now if I
leave the knight and also a my is black
threatening a5 if you're if you're black
do you want to in a perfect world you
know would it work for you to get white
to push the a pawn to the fifth rank if
possible when you want you probably do
yeah Sammy who plays 97 right it and
that's the most natural move it looks
good
Bishop b3 is interesting because it
feels like maybe we're going to get a
little counter play
right there's more than one move for
white though like I don't even have to
play Knight b6 maybe that's the best but
I could also do King D three because if
you take I assume I'm winning this one
yeah it might get a little complicated
over here but no I don't think it will
be I don't think it will be we're our
Knights gonna do the dance he's gonna
mop it up and go home
could Sam if you go back with the new
moves where Bishop e3 mm-hmm we had a
situation where white could ignore the
threat on a four and push B 5 B 5 yeah
but B 5 allows black to trade it all off
you mean a 5 right no no I meant B 5
yeah I was I was I miss thinking
incorrectly a 5 right now the bummer is
it's a it's a reasonable move thing
about but King C forest looks like too
much counter play in fact the only free
pipe he lost but we gonna have something
here so in fact something different
happened and we got Bishop f1 a similar
idea which is to allow the king in
Savion plays Knight b6 check and I'm
gonna guess King e5 is our only move so
as I said before the knight is really
good at knocking that teeny 5 happened
it's good at knocking the King off the
squares and now we need really away for
this King to come over to c5 and we can
see now casados idea is that he can hold
off the king and keep the bishop on the
diagonal so imagine there's not that
many squares on the diagonal for the
bishop right there's not that many
squares so you have to wonder about you
know you have the potential problems of
getting kicked off not so easy for what
to do it but I'm just saying
a dream for white to get him off the
diagonal okay
King f2 was played now this might just
be a way of weighing winning time
because after Bishop d3 the only square
on the diagonal we can come back and
then you're gonna go back 15 minutes
it's you know it's funny it sounds like
a lot but in these positions which
imagine you're you've done a lot of
endgame studies in your life and you
enjoy them kind of like I do my
experience in these positions is you are
going to in order to win you're gonna
have to solve several and game studies
right because there's casada is going to
be able to present multiple problems to
you and then you have to solve them in a
way we've already solved one we got the
King off of our g3 point right but now
we have a different one to solve which
is getting the King out of e5 yeah so I
assume yeah I don't know what else
besides Bishop d3 it's gonna come
there's thinking he's thinking hard
about it guys a fighter I look at him
absolutely I like this web cam stuff I
like that it was not a web cam just the
camp seemed guys body language yeah adds
a completely different component to the
gameplay we're seeing lets while we are
watching the end moments of the
important games of this round let's take
a small break and we'll come back and
and finish up the show all right sounds
good all right we will be back in just a
few moments here with the 2018 winter
chess classic round 8 when you visit st.
Louis you'll probably want to watch the
Cardinals or the Blues what about after
the game heading back to the hotel would
be a major air
instead boogie through the city and
discover the music that gave the Blues
their name at the National Blues Museum
Broadway or stir bar or even the
legendary Blueberry Hill
so whether you love the Cardinals the
Blues or the Blues come play with us
and you guys know I can't play this
right st. Loup is always exploring
[Music]
question on Twitter from dem s I should
not have pronounced that that was a bit
of a champion
[Music]
for those of you who are new to chess it
might look like ba3 is an illegal move
here because white advances pawn two
squares not one but it still is
something we call hustle and you can do
that I get to do it instantly you can't
wait for a move like that say clay King
in seven Kim G - and I'll try because
[Music]
[Music]
all played four against Lawrence and now
he's going to play something against me
which we discussed the playing during
the course of my stay
yeah he told me this is accent g5
this was what I was kind of hoping for
because now I think he practiced I know
who Lawrence this is not how Jeff's
works
certainly will be much much more fun if
chess actually work like this I don't
think it does well maybe it does well
that's me regretting what I just said
how did I get from there to here is a
little bit beyond me and what's worse I
will never hear the end of it my quality
of life has just gone downhill
tremendously because I'm actually
sharing the office with the guy
[Music]
be surprised be intrigued be delighted
the world chess Hall of Fame in st.
Louis is nothing you'd expect and
everything you love three galleries
highlight the history culture and
creativity behind the game explore chess
in ways you never imagined it's a
one-of-a-kind cultural institution where
rare artifacts and world-class art play
together the world chess Hall of Fame
mind art and experience you may have
heard about st. Louis's world-class
museums art history science even magic
but you may not know we have an entire
museum dedicated to play with a 10-story
slide and a ferris wheel on top don't
let all this family fun slide by you
[Music]
those kids it is st. Loup is always
exploring anybody I don't know I just I
I just have a love for the city and I've
always had a love for chess I mean it's
just it's addictive and people study it
they can see it's an unbelievable
preciseness and beauty to the things
that occur on the chessboard wanna wish
you congratulations happy birthday 10th
anniversary and wishing you another
happy 10 years to come
happy 10th anniversary to the st. Louis
Chester French classics and may there be
many more I want to congratulate the
chess club st. Louis on 10 years and
hopefully many more in a very bright
future success ahead thanks for a great
first 10 years and I hope I will
continue to be playing here for the next
10 years and a couple more decades after
that I think without the faint blue with
death Club in de night that they won't
really be the same I would like to say
thank you to Jeanne and Rex for all
they've done the sort of generosity of
spirit they have is something special
and I'm very grateful tonight it would
not be an exaggeration to say that the
Chess Club and scholastic center and
I'll say Louis changed my life and I'm
very grateful for everything it's done
for me and for chess here in the US and
around the world it's been a wonderful
ride you've done so much the chest thank
you so much I'm eminently grateful for
what you've done for this game and we're
looking forward to the next 10 years and
I wish everyone to continue having this
amazing fun the next I don't know
all right I'm really thankful to
everyone here who is helped me at the
club
Tony rich joy Bray and of course Ruxin
ginseng filled so many great events have
happened over these past ten years that
I've been involved in and I'm looking
forward to everything that will happen
in the next ten years as well so I to
the future welcome back to overtime of
the 2018 winter chess classic Ben Simon
and Grandmaster Jessie cry here in the
studio B and we think we have a decision
in Group A and we have a champion and I
don't know that the relay of the moves
is curry lay of the result is correct in
one of the games but I want to start
first of all with Quesada's game with
Savannah right and that is over that is
a draw right and basically you know
savvy undecided know I can do anything
in this position bummer
I would have pushed harder but like I
said maybe my whole dreams the whole
time and you probably read something on
the computer said it was just equal but
anyways they might also be interested
I'll go up there and see what they say
in the post mortem
maybe casado I suspect cuz that it will
be like it was drawn the whole time
we'll see about that and it looks like
he has secured first place with that
draw because in the other game that
where he might have got caught is
Krishna against moku Mian total draw in
this position and they have agreed to
that drop now this game actually just
ended a mere seconds ago and this was
the one that clinched it for casada do
the time constraints I think we should
interview you neski Quesada give him as
champions interview tomorrow okay with
you know championship final round day
but it congratulations to Quesada with
this draw Sasi is not in contention any
more to finish it or tie it first and so
that gives the Cuban the victory okay so
that's gonna do it for today Jessie
right and I'd like to thank all of you
for watching and finally we got into the
chat we're able to answer a question
so join us tomorrow remember tomorrow we
are beginning early 11 a.m. central is
whenever the first moves are played
we'll be on the air two and a half hours
later and hopefully the Group B champion
hasn't been decided by then so we can
have some excitement on the air but you
never know it could be decided early so
visit us chess champs calm starting at
11:00 a.m. hey world championship game
for the winter chess classic final day
it's gonna be a big day on us chess
champs there's not gonna be any shortage
of chess to be certain so we look
forward to seeing you tomorrow at 1:30
p.m. the start of our show and of course
the world championship show beginning at
11:00 a.m. Central Time two hours after
they make the first move in London this
show was presented by the world's
greatest production B team Tammy Hyde
was the streamer Isaac's Ron's graphics
and audio Danny Machuca the technical
director want to thank Jonathan transfer
his help over the weekend and for a
grandmaster jessie cry my name is Ben
Simon until tomorrow we say so long from
the show-me-state
bye bye
[Music]
this has been a presentation of the st.
Louis chess club
you